you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's program
show your stripes the campaign to raise
awareness of how climate change
is happening right now
how increasing temperatures could be
good news for fans of english wine
and the children leading the way to a
green
future i'll be talking to tv presenter
helen skelton
about a competition to help inspire the
next generation
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes
happening to our world right now and
meet those who are coming up with the
solutions
well we start today with a global
campaign to raise awareness of how
climate change
is happening around the world right now
and here on our data dashboard you can
see
the level of human induced warming since
the industrial revolution
it is ticking up the whole time as our
planet
heats up well another way to show that
increase
is the warming stripes these graphics
here are visual representations
of the change in temperature as measured
in each country
over at least the past 100 years they
show how our world is warming
turning from mainly blue in the late
1800s
through to the darker red colors that
you see today
well they were created by professor ed
hawkins a climate scientist at the
university of
reading who joins me now professor
hawkins
good to talk to you it's a pretty stark
visualization when you see it there
on the screen are there any countries
which haven't turned from predominantly
blue to predominantly red
over that period
no every country you look at around the
world has shown this
warming trend and this is illustrated by
the stripes turning from blue to red
wherever you are in the world
and when we look at the picture of the
uk it's interesting isn't it because it
goes from predominantly blue and then
there's a real change around about what
looks to be about the 1990s just talk us
through it
so in the uk we've warmed as well and
that gradual warming started
quite early on in the early 1900s but
then we saw this rapid acceleration
around the world since about the 1960s
or 1970s
and we see that reflected in the uk as
well
and i want to draw our attention as well
to the to the warming stripes that we've
got here for the arctic
because that tells the starkest picture
of all doesn't it because it goes
to pretty much a solid bar of dark red
by the end there the arctic is warming
faster than anywhere else on the planet
more than twice as fast as the global
average
and that is melting the sea ice as we've
seen over the last 40 years or so
we've seen a huge reduction in the
undersea ice covering the arctic
the story though isn't new particularly
not to climate
scientists what is the point of these
warming stripes
the idea is to start conversations about
the reality of our warming world
they can be used in so many different
ways people have got masks or mugs or
badges people have even painted their
cars in these stripes
to highlight the the reality of our
warming world and start conversations
with friends and family
about that reality do you have
confidence that
climate change is being taken more
seriously now
it certainly has been taken more
seriously in the uk we've seen the
government commit to
net zero emissions by 2050 we need the
policies to get there
and it's going to be extremely difficult
for us all to achieve that goal
but it is definitely possible and we
need to do it professor ed hawkins great
to talk to you thank you
well let's take a look at today's other
climate news now
in the western united states people are
being told to expect water shortages and
wildfires
as a heatwave worsens the mega drought
there
temperatures have reached 50 degrees
celsius in parts of california
which is experiencing the highest levels
of hot weather in history
the mega drought is a naturally
occurring event it started back in 2000
but researchers say climate change is
making it more severe
and angelina jolie has visited a refugee
camp
in burkina faso to mark world refugee
day
the actor says the refugee crisis is
only going to get worse
as conflict and climate change force
hundreds of millions of people
to leave their homes
and the national trust is urging people
to respect nature
as they look forward to a summer of
staycations
with most people expected to holiday in
the uk this year
the trust is asking everyone to tidy up
after themselves in a bid to keep
beauty spots clean they said cleaning up
after visitors diverts rangers from
their conservation work
now the popularity of english wine is
increasing and climate
change could be a factor the south downs
is already home to 51 vineyards and 11
wineries
and as warmer summers become more
frequent it's predicted that
great growing opportunities in the area
will increase
in a moment i'll be speaking to an
english winemaker but first
here's your 60-second crash course in
[Music]
viticulture
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we can bring in tomorrow roberts
now ceo of
ridgeview wine estate you're based in
ditchling
in the south downs tamara good to talk
to you
a talk of this boom in winemaking in the
south downs are you feeling it
well certainly there's been such a
massive increase
um in interest in our industry and
investment
into it as well over the last
particularly five to ten years so yeah
very exciting times
and how has the way you go about
winemaking changed because of the
climate
we were talking about this earlier and
actually you know i think one of the
sort of standout
um figures that we had was uh
three of the last four harvests have
actually started
in september whereas in the previous or
20 20 years prior to that
it'd be very rare to see a harvest begin
um
outside of the first or second week of
october so um
you know we certainly have seen um our
harvest states being brought forward
uh due to weather conditions in the in
the growing season so that's been
something we can't dispute at all so
so changes around those sorts of things
and being perhaps a little bit more
conscious of higher sugar levels
um than we were in the past because for
us that's quite critical for sparkling
wine production
and do you have to even be thinking now
about adaptations that you need to make
for future climate change
i think it's interesting it's um it's
difficult to predict
exactly what that's going to materialize
um as in in our areas because um
we're not entirely sure whether we're
going to see more rainfall at certain
times of the year perhaps in more
difficult times a year for us
during the growing season um and so
to make adjustments now when we're not
really sure how the climate change is
actually going to manifest
uh for us is very tricky so what we're
doing is just being as we would normally
be
taking each season as it comes and
reacting to what's in front of us at
that point
well cheers to that uh tomorrow really
good to talk to you thank you
thank you school pupils across the uk
are being given the chance to have their
voices heard by world leaders at the cop
26 summit in november
and come up with innovative ways to save
the planet in the process
the voices for a green future
competition has been launched by the
national grid
to inspire children to come up with new
ways to help tackle climate change
here's a taster of some of their ideas
everybody
has to have at least three trees in
their garden
investing more into wind solar
stop people from going on airplanes
save electricity by not having any
lights on for like the rest of your life
a battery powered um jet pack hamster
power trains
giant mutated hamster power thing to get
a big zip fire
well the television presenter helen
skelton is one of the judges of that
competition
and joins me now hello helen they're
certainly not short of ideas are they
the younger generation
and you know what i think we can learn
so much from young people
we know that 80 of kids feel that you
know
climate change is their responsibility
86 percent of them feel empowered to do
something about it
and that's why national grid wanted to
talk to kids and get them talking about
all of these ideas because
the brilliant thing about young people
is they don't see what can't be done
they think about what can be done i'm
not suggesting for one second any
scientists will think we should have
giant mutated hamster-powered trains but
it might make somebody think
is there an alternative way to power
planes or to power cars which is
brilliant
and what's so powerful about it is that
leaders will see
videos like that in glasgow at cop26 and
it's a powerful reminder isn't it
that it's their generation's future
that's at stake
absolutely and so often you know we
think oh we should be telling kids to do
this and we should be telling kids to do
that
but actually i think what's brilliant
about this national grid competition is
that we're putting
the onus on kids like you say they're
the ones who are going to be the leaders
of the future and if those kids have
anything to go by
we're going to be in safe hands but in
2050 they're the ones who are going to
have the responsibility for this and
they're the ones that actually at the
minute think let's turn the lights off
let's walk to school
let's recycle it's already in their
minds to do the little things and if all
of those little things add up
then collectively it will make a big
difference hopefully and helen it
already in their minds as you're saying
a really sad statistic one in three
almost having nightmares
about the environment it just goes to
show
how important it is to kids though you
know and it just goes to show that it is
on their radar and it is something that
they're thinking about and they're
talking about
and for me there wasn't one kid who
didn't talk about trees
and i know for my kids you know i always
say to them we're not getting in the car
we're going to walk because if you want
to climb trees like you love doing
then that's how we're going to protect
it and i think it's just about engaging
in a way that works for them
nobody's talking about scaremongering or
talking about
you know that well's going to end you we
just need to build on the fact that they
feel empowered that they have the
opportunity to change things going
forward and i think
as i've said so many times it's the
little things that we can all do
together collectively and they're the
little things you can still at home
that will provide a basis for us to be
able to tackle climate change
i love how excited kids get about wind
and solar and ultimately
clean and green energy is going to be so
key to fighting climate change and kids
already are clued into that you know
it's not alien to kids to
see wind turbines or have solar panels
on houses so hopefully we can get them
excited about those possibilities in the
future
something tells me you're going to have
a tough job picking a winner helen
skelton good to talk to you thank you
thanks for having me well that is
everything from us for today on the
daily climate show
tomorrow as the world tries to move away
from fossil fuels is enough being done
to help those who rely on those
industries for work we're going to be
finding out more about what's known as
the
just transition that's at the same time
tomorrow
here on sky news hope to see you then
you